with us to discuss that is LaRhonda
hunter who owns i'm jay kapoor under the
controls of obamacare my business has
been restricted from expansion I'm from
Fort Worth Texas I own five fantastic
camp Fantastic Sams here secular talk to
me that we employ between 45 and is that
the lesser judge sister employ my
original plan wants to open more salons
and employ more people however under
Obamacare I am restricted because I it
requires me to furnish health insurance
if I employ more than 50 personally the
property my industry is very thin and
I'm not a wealthy person so it's
impossible for me to grow my business my
question to you senator Sanders is how
do I grow my business how do I employ
raising the prices to my customers or
lowering wages to my own 'filling altars
in The Jungle Book
LaRhonda run oh you own five salons
that's correct and you employ close to
50 people just under and what kind of
health insurance do you provide to them
zero I don't have none probably no
health insurance correct she's gonna
vilify your wife let me be let me give
you an answer you will not be happy with
and that I think that for businesses
that employ 50 people or more given the
nature of our dysfunctional health care
system right now where most people do
get their health insurance through the
places that they work I'm sorry I think
that in America today everybody should
have health care and if you have more
than 50 people you know what I think I'm
afraid to tell you you you have three
houses one is only 40 minutes from the
other one up on Lake Champlain you don't
even ask her about her profit margins
even ask her how many people is she
employs how many them are part-time how
many
been forced onto working part-time
because of Obamacare because of the
current laws that forced small business
was 50 people is not a lot at all you
piece of [ __ ]
and this is so clear right now when he
tries to say we're talking about the
multi-billion dollar corporations we're
talking about the big people this woman
probably barely earns a six-figure
income instead I wouldn't be surprised
if most year she makes less than those
50 employees that she's talking about
you piece of [ __ ] everyone watching this
show right now knows somebody who
probably has a business on that scale of
size when Bernie Sanders says
forevermore that he's only going after
the top one percent right here he's
going after women like that he is not a
nice guy he is buying your vote he is a
walking talking bumbling piece of human
[ __ ]
what's the drink to that this video
subscribe by clicking the button that
says subscribe if you're not aware of it
now there's no way you're learning the
internet at this point I'm not going to
help you but this was clipped from my
daily show available exclusively to
lotto with credit.com slash mug club
members of your student military or
veteran entering that promo code it's
less than six dollars a month and you
get daily content no more clips Plus
this hand etched mug
oh I just when I feel it I got a chill
like on the inside